doit descendre
tu as le contrôle les gars qui tombent c'est parti
appeler ne contrôle pas en arrière
j'aimerais avoir les repères
dans lesquels vit ma mère et une meilleure maison
ouais peut-être
papa où es-tu sur mon bateau où d'autre
David celui-ci est définitivement  plus grand que
le dernier,
vous pouvez le voir oh écoutez-moi, vous devez
vous rendre à terre aussi vite que possible papa
Moïse,
vous
avez empiré bien pire dr.  Okun tu es
bien éveillé alors pourquoi crient-ils non
non que là ils ne crient pas
ils font la fête
au moins ton père a épargné le bien de l'
éléphant pour lui
regarde le crash de Roswell en 47 le fermier
qui a pris contact a dessiné le même monsieur  et
chaque fois que j'interviewe un de mes
patients et que je leur montre cela, ils
expriment tous la même peur émotionnelle et je
ne pense pas que ce soit un cercle la nuit où le
navire s'est allumé, j'ai eu la vision la plus forte
que j'aie jamais eue
et j'ai dessiné ceci
c'est incroyable  comment as-tu déchiffré tant de
choses dans notre langue ils nous chassaient
nous devons apprendre à les chasser
ici nous allons bien venir pour toi bébé
qu'est-ce que c'est un laser extraterrestre non c'est du
laser seokhun attention
tu devais scotcher les cristaux que j'ai construit
ce retour en 94 a dû le mettre de côté, donc
après l'effondrement du secteur trois,
mettez-le ici
qu'est-ce que cette chose fait ici bon garçon
allez vous tenir là-bas attendez une seconde quel
effondrement sommes-nous sûrs que cette chose est sûre
à utiliser hautement improbable clair